andréanne st-arnaud que l'on accueille
avec joie pas de journée christian
dufour étienne leblanc alors là on est
équipé pour parler du plan vert
pas à peu près parce que bon certains
disent tu un plan trop ambitieux d'eau
disent au contraire c'est pas assez
ambitieux étienne donnez-nous vos
lumières un peu là ce qu'on a présenté à
ce que c'est le minimum est ce que c'est
plus que le minimum ce qu'un ca de la
vision essaye de me donner un sens à
tout ça je crois que c'est un petit peu
plus le minimum faut quand même suivre
le fait que c'est le je crois que cod
plan au niveau historique au québec
entre un des plans les plus ambitieux
parce que il y mer il était si vous
voulez une vision économique dans la
lutte contre les changements climatiques
est assez nouveau parce que les plans
verts qu'on a eu au fil des ans sous
jean charest sous madame marois souche
et les couillard était assez faible
donc pour quand même souligner ça mais
il y à de grandes lacunes dans ce plan
là notamment presque 60% des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre qui sont un peu
laissés en plan et pour lesquelles on
devra les réduire mon ne sais pas
comment on ne sait pas avec quel argent
60% c'est quand même énorme et d'autres
moi c'est un plat qui focaliser
totalement sur l'électrification des
transports une bonne chose aussi le
transport c'est le secteur qui émet le
plus de gaz à effet de serre au québec
ces 43 % de nos émissions c'est
important de s'y intéresser ici je crois
ce qui avait marqué les anciens
gouvernements on souligne ce camp m mais
le fait qu' on est tellement focalisés
sur l'électrification qu'on oublie les
aspects très importants pour des plans
de lutte contre les changements
climatiques les aspects d'aménagement du
territoire d'aménagement urbain dans les
villes de mobilité urbaine des choses
qui font vraiment la différence sont un
peu relégués en annexe si vous voulez
quasiment non ce dans ce clan qui nous a
été présentée aujourd'hui on va y
revenir tour de table dont paul journet
qu'est-ce que vous votre analyse de ce
qu'on a présenté aujourd'hui on a
beaucoup mis le focus sera
l'interdiction de vendre des voitures un
sens
2035 mais c'est quand même dans 15 ans
oui puis on ne sait pas précisément à
quoi ressemblera le marché de ventes de
véhicules dans 2035 mons et en gros on
se dirige vers un marché plus en plus
électrique
et c'est possible que ce qui est annoncé
aujourd'hui finalement ne change rien
parce que le marché se dirigeait déjà à
cet endroit
cela dit pour ce qui est des cris
fication des transports autant chez les
particuliers que le transport commercial
ça c'est assurément le volet phare du
plan du gouvernement
le problème c'est tout le reste le plan
qui a été présenté est très bon c'est
seulement que c'est incomplet et je
pense qu en matière de lutte aux
changements climatiques faut toujours
revenir aux chiffres assez simple la
science nous donne un objectif de
réduction de grs et à partir de là et
des décisions politiques pour savoir
comment on arrive à ces réductions et on
n'a même pas la moitié des réductions
souhaité monsieur legault a raison de
dire que la cible de 2020 on ne
l'atteint de repas et ça c'est l'échec
des libéraux et cet échec rend encore
plus difficile l'atteinte de la
prochaine cible pour 2030
parce qu'on part de plus loin donc il a
raison de dire ça mais quand même ce qui
est présenté est insuffisant et pour le
résumer en une idée toute simple ce qui
manque c'est tour sg monsieur ginestet
de déplaire aux gens ça c est très
frustré les gens les taxes toute forme d
co officialité tout ce qui les
bouleverse dans leurs habitudes ce
gouvernement veut parler la poudre et
j'allais vous posez la question parce
que monsieur legault était clair
là-dessus là il dit on est déjà assez
taxés au québec dit il on va pas en
rajouter des taxes sur les grosses
cylindrées ou sur d'autres sur le nombre
de kilomètres et c'est là qu'on pourrait
imaginer ces noms exacts parce que en
fait il sait très bien que ce serait pas
très populaire parce que c'est très
clair quand on regarde les chiffres de
ventes de véhicules par exemple la
popularité des petites voitures des
berlines chez terra c'est en recul de
façon constante depuis plusieurs années
les gens veulent des gros véhicules
veulent d
us mais c'est un peu ça le problème en
fait parce que il n'ya pas d'incitatif
comme le suggère paul avec deux
l'écofiscalité la dure soit qu'on
récompense un bon comportement en
octroyant des crédits par exemple
lorsqu'on a un comportement plus
écoénergétiques et qu'on impose une taxe
pour inciter les gens à changer à
modifier leur choix si vous voulez ça ne
changera pas demain matin et on se
refait un peu sur l'idée que
l'électrification des transports tout
mais en fait je n'y a pas beaucoup de
gens qui sont contre le principe qu'on
me la vertu mais il ya encore des freins
à l'achat de véhicules automobiles ont
fait le pari que de manière un peu
automatique la technologie sera plus
répandu plus accessible le coi qui a
toujours pas de garantie à ce niveau
laisse que ce serait vraiment suffisant
pour que les gens fassent ce choix et
fasse ce virage il n'y a pas de garantie
pour l'instant et on veut produire
pondent il n'y a pas d'annoncé que
monsieur fidji bonita la chasse on veut
faire produire des camions des véhicules
ici même on veut développer ce champ
leur expertise à suivre christian vous
en êtes où dans l'appréciation de ce
plan vert je trouve que c'est assez
intéressant de départ il était très peu
porté sur ce dossier là et les gens qui
l'ont élu principalement non plus donc
il ya fait quand même pas mal de chemin
paris stand by mail c'est clair que la
marque de commerce de françois legault
c'est l'économie qui ont le sens dans ce
plan là donc le plan est pas idéal
c'est sûr qu'il va déplaire à tous ceux
pour qui la lutte contre les changements
climatiques qui s'excuse moi de venir au
vivier on n'est pas dans des halles on
n'est pas dans l'absolu je pense que
françois legault il semble vouloir moins
sauver la planète tenir compte de la
réalité québécoise
rappelons quand même que les québécois
le québec c'est la promesse au canada où
il ya le moins d'émissions de gaz à
effet de serre père capita donc c'est
exactement
donc françois legault joue là dessus
c'est clair que pour lui sa priorité
c'est les connus mais le principe sciant
les montants qui sont prévues en matière
de transport entre 3
6 milliards $ c'est important aussi
parce est présenté dans une optique ou
l'année prochaine ils vont avoir mais
les ajustements
donc c'est sûr que ça satisfont pas tous
les gens pour qui l'environnement c'est
une donne une énorme priorité mais
tenant compte de ce qu'est françois
legault qui a fait un choix réel et il y
à couches de quelque chose qui est quand
même intéressant de sérieux etienne
c'est ce que des gens bien donc il ya
quand même d un monde associatif chat on
annonce 6,7 milliards qu'est ce qu'on
doit comprendre de saint etienne que
c'est un bon montant d'argent mais que
ça on prendra encore plus sa vie dans le
fond ce cas pas dans ce plan là c'est
d'aller encore plus en profondeur c'est
à dire de remettre en question le modèle
économique dont on a développé au québec
c'est à dire un modèle qui est focalisée
sur l'étalement urbain est un modèle qui
focaliser sur la voiture et ça ça va
prendre beaucoup plus que dix ans pour
changer ça est ce que ce qu'on veut ce
que le souvent on ne dit pas c'est
qu'une politique climatique
elle prend du temps se mettre en place
il reste dix ans pour atteindre 6,6
c'est pas assez je crois pas qu'on va
les atteindre en fait parce que une fois
qu'on met en place des mesures ça prend
des années avant de voir les effets
c'est très bien qu'on n'est pas du lit
qu'on aille de l'avant avec les grands
projets de transport en commun par
exemple qu'on nous a annoncé à montréal
québec à gatineau et longueuil laval
c'est formidable c'est 15 milliards de
dollars c'est de l'argent dit il c'est
un investissement qui va faire des
petits mais c'est pas demain la veille
qu'on mémoriser fait de ses
investissements sur les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre - christian repris puis
aussi on est quand même en politique et
françois legault de 50 quand même de sa
base politique et qui me croque son
choix en dehors des grandes villes qui
sont entendre en lieux pour qui le taux
important donc de rien grand pragmatisme
là dedans il est tout seul s'échelonnant
sur plusieurs années je trouve que tout
le monde trouve ça peut être un bon
début la part de quelqu'un dont la
priorité je le rappelle c'est
l'économique est pas là dessus avant
d'aller à la position je vous garde
après mais un bon début oui un bon début
mais je reviens à l'idée des chiffres si
on est d'accord avec ce que la science
dit c'est pas suffisant pour atteindre
les chiffres se le dit peut-être un
dernier commentaire sur l'âme
de françois legault faut le reconnaître
ce plan est très précisément chiffrée on
n'est pas que dans les paroles
et ça on voit l' influence de monsieur
legault en ce sens là c'est un aspect
positif et aussi le fait qu'à chaque
année il sera révisé
et on peut avoir un suivi de
l'efficacité des mesures pour pouvoir
corriger le tir
année après année mais on va pas mal de
titres à corriger si on veut atteindre
l'objectif
un pragmatisme notez-vous très bien
étienne merci beaucoup toujours un
plaisir de vous accueillir avec votre
science
après la pause restait l'homme de
l'émission revient avec le panel on va
parler de cette bataille quand même de
garda d'un côté la caisse des dépôts de
l'autre le sujet plus globalement c'est
qu'est ce qu'on doit faire pour protéger
nos sièges sociaux ici on en parle dans
deux minutes
alors vous avez peut-être assisté à
l'entrevue que m'a donnée stéphane
crétier ce matin le grand patron de
garda world c'est chaud ciel à montréal
je fends temps d'un petit extrait où il
dénonce l'attitude de la caisse de dépôt
en reviennent alors vous demander à la
caisse avec l'argent des contribuables
de financer une entreprise américaine
bon est-ce que c'est notre compétiteur
direct qu'est ce que cet investissement
la réduit de fait la presse enfin
éditoriaux ce matin en vous et moi c'est
un peu comme si la caisse investit dans
ces données la bonne le numéro un
mondial contre couche-tard
alors je le disais c'est rare qu'un
entrepreneur publiquement s'en prennent
comme ça à la caisse les gens là qu est
un joueur incontournable
andréanne mais monsieur crétier était
furieux parce que il ya un compétiteur
américain dont la caisse est en partie
propriétaire qui veut acheter la même
chose que lui
exactement on parle ici de g4s qui est
un leader mondial dans le monde de la
sécurité qui est quatre fois plus gros
que garda et même plus pour rappeler que
cette entreprise la plus d'un demi
million d'employés garde en à 100 milles
à peu près dans le monde et stéphane
crétier en fait ne s'en cache pas il a
toujours voulu faire de garder le numéro
un et il dit que c'est à peu près la
seule voie pour y arriver le problème
c'est que l'offre a été très mal reçue
on sent que déjà il ya un froid entre
garda et g4s
on a rendu l'offre monde hostile si vous
voulez long le présenter aux
actionnaires de g4s le conseil
d'administration l'a refusée ils ne
veulent rien savoir de cette france là
sauf qu effectivement dans la course est
là et d'universo donc ce joueur
américain
il semble que g4s après l'offre hostile
de garde à ce soit chercher un chevalier
blanc quelqu'un d'autre qui seraient
intéressés à la lâcheté pour
concurrencer garda si vous voulez et le
problème effectivement c'est que la
caisse est derrière à la galerie semé
ultima dont paul on pourrait se
retrouver avec alain cachette le géant
mondial qu'il vient donc un groupe
extraordinairement puissant laquelle
serait co propriétaire de ce gros plein
et garda que chez nous ben fraîche ou
blinde
oui c'est une histoire très étrange j'ai
plus de questions que de pignon sur ce
sujet là premièrement je me demande pour
le rappeler quand même la caisse a été
évoqué dans l'interview au fait une
offre un milliard de dollars américains
approuvée par le conseil
d'administration et garde à leur refuser
c'était une offre pour lui permettre
d'acquérir le compétiteur donc pourquoi
est ce que cette offre a été refusée s
il y avait des conditions qui étaient
assujettis ou est-ce que garda tout
simplement retrouver une meilleure offre
en se finançant un prêtre chrétien
deuxièmement
deuxièmement quand même donc qu en garde
à son offre a été refusée ont cédé fois
quand on est quelqu'un qui ferait une
offre d'achat hostile ça éveille
l'ambition de notre possible acquéreur
dont l'entreprise dans laquelle l'acteur
avait départ mais est ce que la caisse
jouer un rôle
et si oui lequel dans cette nouvelle
offre d'achat et enfin la 30e gardois
il ya des emplois perdus mais dans
quelle mesure est ce que cette crainte
là est fondée et sérieuse une tête en
terminant pour appliquer la pièce c'est
pas inhabituel qui avaient des intérêts
dans différentes entreprises
compétitrices par exemple snc-lavalin et
wsp mais dans ce cas-ci quel type
d'offre précisément avait-elle offert à
garda et quel a été son rôle dans
l'acquisition à la suite de l'eau
projetée par garda vraiment ces dix
questions pour lesquelles j'aimerais
avoir des réponses à plusieurs questions
et en effet et christian c'est rare
qu'on lève le voile sur ses batailles de
financiers qui d'habitude se déroule à
11 heures le soir loin tout le monde
puis des milliards pisi puis ça là il ya
le choc de deux personnages quand même
assez influent la caisse à côté puis
garda de l'eau oui
puis on découvre un personnage aussi
critique que je ne connaissais pas ils
étaient impressionnants safa soyez à
tour eu la clède je pense qu'il y aurait
peut-être gagné à être connue auparavant
parce qu'on a beaucoup parlé de florent
québec conduit dans le passé cette chose
des fleurons qu'elle est mal puissant
l'allèle on découvre que garda garde là
c'était vraiment un fleuron qui semble
bien fonctionner beaucoup de disques aux
techniques de la façade de très très
compliqué tout seul puis je pas sûr que
le téléspectateur their comprennent
qu'ils comprennent des détails comme moi
d'ailleurs mon la question que je me
pose c'est d'abord une plaidoirie très
clairement adressé à françois legault
s'adresse vraiment françois legault rang
puis si vous êtes un entrepreneur comme
moi vous avez fondé à frappe capable de
convaincre françois legault du
bien-fondé en fait de son action puis
deuxième manche et quel point si
françois legault en fait été convaincu
par monsieur précise également françois
legault la passivité réalisme à
d'influer sur les décisions de la caisse
c'est ça qui m'intéresse
ce qu'au fond la caisse de dépôt est
vraiment prisonnière de ses deux mandats
puisque le dos si perso points
importants j'ai ce presque parce que
c'est dangereux vraiment complexe au
siège social est ce qui bloque rien
j'avais mes raisons mais la question de
rien on dit je dois vous laisser aller
vous avez votre émission qui suit la
nôtre je vous laisse aller merci de vos
lumières sur ces questions économiques
on se reparle puis je vais finir avec
mes deux camarades sur le sur la coved
quand même on va reparler de gardien et
de la caisse est pas fini comme je le
disais la coved de nouveaux vaccins ce
serait une bonne nouvelle aujourd'hui
et là on jongle au québec avec la
fermeture des écoles pendant un mois
durant ce décembre ou en janvier à peu
près où vous en êtes dans l'analyse de
tous âges commence avec vous christian
moment j'en ai de nouveau vaccin je
pense qu'il faut en parler on sait que
tu serais pas encore arrivé mais il ya
tellement des primes que le le dossier
positif à lens bon j'en suis c'est que
c'est que je suis un peu surréaliste de
voir enfin le gouvernement jongle avec
l'idée qu'à noël peut-être on
permettrait des réunions de 5 6 12
personnes c'est pas du tout réaliste ce
moi je trouve qu actuellement autour de
moi je ne parle pas de kobe d'idiot
parce qu'on paiera sioniste puis
d'irresponsables je trouve que très
largement les gens interprètent les
consignes à leur façon et les consignes
du gouvernement j'espère que les
autorités en sont conscients qu'ils ne
sont plus observer strictement parler
des citoyens c'est ça la réalité
donc on nous dise quand noël je pense
qu'à noël les gens vont peut-être
comprendre le message global est de dire
est ce qu'on va permettre des réunions
de 7 de 10 personnes on sent un peu
bizarre j'espère qu'il sait s'ils sont
conscients que les 25 30
oui je sais pas quoi des ces cantons aux
jambes qu'avec les chefs disais tout à
l'heure
est-ce qu'on va permettre neuf ou treize
personnes franchement je comprend
l'interrogation de christian qui est
légitime mais moi je donnerai de la
contrepartie je pense qu'il ya deux
arguments qui militent pour permettre de
petites réunions à noël le premier c'est
celui de la santé mentale
le second c'est dire que si on interdit
complètement toute forme de
rassemblement à noël les gens ne
respecteront poste et c'est peut-être
préférable d'y arriver avec de légères
permission qui seront respectés au lieu
d'une interdiction mur à mur qui sera
jugée tellement déraisonnable qu'elle ne
sera pas respectée à tout le moins c'est
en ce moment là vraiment une
préoccupation du gouvernement et ce
dossier là et inévitablement lié à celui
des écoles parce que si on perd mais des
rassemblements limités
évidemment ça augmente les risques
d'explosion donc est ce que en
contrepartie on pourrait être devancé le
congé scolaire le prolonger ou le
devancer et le prolonger
oui les deux dossiers là ça fait partie
d'une même réflexion pour le
gouvernement williams des conséquences
pour les parents bien sûr parce que oui
c'est un con que jamais ouais c'est très
concret pour les parents il faut que les
consignes qu'ils soient raisonnables
irrationnelle parce que moi je vois 2 2
hectares actuellement mais comme
dynamique on nous dit au fond la
deuxième vague s'accentue c'est
dramatique
faut vraiment observer les consignes
peut-être ajouter autre chose puis aussi
dans la réalité moi ce que je vois je le
répète c'est des gens qui ne sont pas
irresponsables mais des gens qui ont le
goût de vivre qui sont pendantes ou là
de tout ça et qui interprète un petit
peu les choses il faut vraiment que le
gouvernement tienne compte de ce style
dans un partage des tracts et à l'arrêté
convention doit survivre aux québécois
merci beaucoup de cette cascade de amman
un peu particulier on va pas reproduire
sur un meilleur et d y avait du congrès
cbo ratisse vous les dossiers comité
économique puis 1 520 mille personnes
seront 16 mai le québec garde à vie à
l'employeur au québec pour les connais
pas obligé avant l'entrevue parce que
longtemps que le mardi puis l'aiment pas
mesdames et messieurs au revoir à demain